wow
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on Friday
night yep it's a holiday weekend yep
having our first drink of the night at
least in the United States getting
settled in
got a lot of stuff taken care of
got rid of [__] an old act uh got rid
of that acasso brave seven that we got
got a new got another one and then
exchanged the old one because it had a
defect in it so we got two cameras now
yeah like the battery the battery life
uh indicator didn't work it said it was
Zero all the time yes it was Zero all
the time no matter even though it was
running
and um and it would go to 100 when you
plugged it in
and it acted a little glitchy I don't
think it was right
so we just swapped it out yes we're
ready to go so we have two uh new ones
now yeah that are that work perfectly
see or seem to be so far so far I'm just
trying to learn how to [__]
manage the SD card memory and stuff in
it and just get all the little features
it's it's kind of like a like a GoPro
it's a half the cost of a GoPro but
comparable performance so it's a Chinese
GoPro yeah that's what it is I think
they're like 160 something dollars right
I got it yeah I got it for 160 because I
had like a coupon yeah they're normally
like 170 I think yeah I got a coupon for
like twenty dollars on for some [__]
like that like an equivalent GoPro would
be like a GoPro I think it's called
something rather black
HERO Black I think is what it's called
and I think they're close to 400.
um they are a little bit better image
quality but we don't need real good
image quality for for what we're doing
the
the microphone isn't great but it's okay
uh but the microphone isn't great on a
[__] GoPro either
there's a bunch of accessories it takes
GoPro accessories so
it's a fun camera when they're working
yeah because we definitely wanted two
that were like because they're only
about this big yeah they're little
they're like that I'll go get one man
it's cool the only thing is is on the on
the GoPro black if you point it towards
yourself the the screen on the front
automatically flips over it's got
gyroscope in it and if you turn it away
then the screen on the back turns on
with this one you got to manually
turn the front or the back screen on it
doesn't do it just by breaking it around
well you know it's cheaper so you're not
going to get all the bells and whistles
yeah but you got it go up to 4K and 4K
and like [__] 80 frames a minute or
60 frames a minute and then go all the
way down to 720 at like 20 excuse me uh
20 frames a second I think is the lowest
it'll go it's got image of stabilization
got certain settings you need kind of
like a lot of frames per per second to
get image stabilization but just
learning how to do it the only thing I
don't like about it so far is that the
software that manages the camera so you
can upload it into a tablet or a or a
software or or a tablet or a PC it's
only available that was weird yeah so
let's see that light does that [__]
randomly it's only available for mobile
devices
we can't find a
software for a laptop or or a PC which
which have more memory in them so it
would be easier to work through that you
know but
whatever
you gotta have to do it through tablets
yeah because you got to get it up a
Dropbox inside
yeah so I can download them and edit I
mean you're right on my computer
that I had another idea though what's
that can you just remove the SD card is
there an SD card reader and you can just
get it that way right into a laptop
well I don't know mine won't do it
because that laptop's like super old
okay I can hook up my phone to it so I
thought that I would just be able to
hook up your hook up the camera directly
to the laptop but it doesn't see it for
whatever reason
because I got a I got a little SD card
readers you can pop an SD card in and
it'll go in like a thumb drive yeah
maybe you can just get the videos
mechanically out of the [__] side of
the camera and just plug it into the
yeah that might work that probably that
way you don't worry of any of the
wireless connections yeah it's probably
because I mean what I do with my phone
because I have a I have a Mac laptop
from 2008. you guys are in the lab but
hey it's still working I had to buy a
new battery for it a couple years back
but other than that it's still kicking
along
um but I have like a little Android app
on that where I can just hook up my
phone to it directly and just pull files
off of it and I thought that I would
just be able to do that with the camera
because it does like you know hook up to
it and [__] like that but it for some
reason it doesn't recognize it and I
have a um I mean this PC that we're
using to stream on this is um you know
this is like a PC laptop and I have a
Mac one too but neither one of them work
uh granther said is your new sexy time
live stream up and running no not yet
um we like I said we kind of wanted to
get some videos like video in the can
um so that when we start live streaming
we'll already have like some video clips
up for sale so we're still working on
those we have um I'm gonna shit's real
good we have a couple of videos that are
finished I've tried some of it out it's
good
this is so funny it's so funny
I don't well I mean you know you might
as well because
[Laughter]
let's talk about it later Jenny made
damn some solo videos that [__] I
couldn't resist I made well I made one
when you were at home like he knew that
I was gonna make one that night because
I said oh man I have an idea like I'm
gonna make one where you're not here
yeah and so I had like an idea for it
and then like I didn't um and then he
didn't see it for like a really long
time and I showed it to him like over
over the weekend like last weekend I
showed it to him I was like wow
she's good it's a mind [__]
um because uh
she's pretty she's cheating on me yeah
with y'all well I got the idea because I
got that idea from you actually because
one video that we got that light is
driving yeah
it's just randomly changing colors
um I got the idea from you because one
of the videos that we were doing that
we've finished that we've edited
um you kind of made a joke where because
we were filming it with two cameras and
he was like looking at the camera and
saying oh show that to your other
boyfriend or something like that I'm
like oh my God that's pretty funny and
so I was like so I was like I'm gonna do
a whole scenario
like that he's out of the house so I'm
like talking to you know the other
boyfriend yeah and so he thought that
was very funny he's like yeah that was a
good idea I was like yeah I thought it
was a good idea Jenny of course you know
even before and started this show Jenny
wrote erotica you know which is that's
girl porn so she comes up with some
[__] crazy ideas
I do my my brain is a crazy Place yeah
she comes up it's a good idea it's a
crazy hold on let me go get some more
ice Tammy says uh reminds me of the
Eddie is our joke about the printer the
computer not seeing each other yeah I
remember that show too
it's a printer it's there
I can see I can access printer
I know right that's exactly yeah I don't
understand it I don't understand why my
laptop can see the phone and I can pull
files off of my phone but it can't see a
camera like I have other cameras that
hook right up to the thing and you can
pull files off that all day long so I
don't know why that camera is different
although was the camera okay well here's
the question I think yeah I was gonna
get just more ice but okay um it doesn't
need more ice okay
is the um the camera that I tried to
hook up to that was that the old one
that we sent that we sent back yeah oh
well maybe it might be a difference
maybe
um one of the new ones at work because
maybe that one was like not working
right because there were some other
things about it which yeah which weren't
working right yeah the the battery power
level indicator wasn't indicating
acted a little glitchy and would do
strange things every now and then it
wasn't predictable
so I think that it it had some kind of
software problem what are you doing
Pokey she's messing up
here like tearing up the carpet back
there
slasher Fred said since you guys did a
discussion uh on Vincent Price one of
these days on your scare Salon Channel
you should do one of your uh top 13
Ghosts of Scooby-Doo episodes that's
actually a really good idea well I
already did I did a couple videos about
like my favorite spooky Looney Tunes
cartoons
um because I've done like some animated
stuff on there as well like I did that
[__] weird Jack In the Beanstalk that
yeah Japan would you know what I mean
the anime one I remember that I thought
was a fever dream until like I saw it
later I'm like oh my God it's real
because I saw it so many times as a kid
and then every time I brought it up to
somebody they didn't know what I was
talking about so I thought maybe I
imagine it but then like I saw it again
I'm like okay because it's it's pretty
trippy it's pretty weird but yeah
um but yeah so but yeah we are honestly
um I kind of feel like just from the
discussions we've been having about the
new uh Endeavor is I kind of feel like
the live streaming is gonna be maybe
where the money is if we're gonna be
making some money but so I would like to
have some videos available but I kind of
do want to start with the live streaming
like soon you know what I mean everybody
says that's where the body is if it
takes a long time to make money off
video yeah because I mean when you sell
video clips you're only selling it for
like a couple of bucks yeah you know I
mean so you have to sell a lot of them
and you have to have a lot of them
available it's a big catalog catalog
that has to have good content on it and
it has to be on all platforms so
it according according to uh to Bill
who's a friend of mine in the industry
it took them
several years
uh to get enough material out there and
what they're shooting is [__] super
hardcore
I mean
I would never his wife's starring in it
I would never [__] I would never ask
a wife to do with this with this but you
know this is this is them that that's
there there yeah I mean she seems to be
into it yeah you know it's it's gang
bang level [__] okay and uh
it took them
several years to get where you'd break
that one thousand dollar a month just in
video sales
most of it was in streaming
yeah
streaming stuff they had so many uh uh
revenue streams coming in
they're all from different platforms
most of it most of it ended up being
streaming
not so much video sales
yeah a long time you know they had to
have close to 400 videos out there right
on all the platforms yeah and there are
a lot I mean that's going to be barely
you know time consuming too like putting
them yeah up on those but and it was
costing him with
STD testing and all the [__] rent and
hotel rooms and ex and hiring Hired Guns
and hired Talent cost about a thousand
dollars per video to to produce
sometimes they have
got it cut down to where they would
lay all that money out but then use the
hotel room to shoot two or three of them
in the night well yeah I mean you might
as well while you got it right that's
like some Roger Corman he's like the
Roger Corman thing
don't waste it they're releasing them
out of order or production so so the so
the the public can't tell that
these were all shot on the same night or
three or 40s were shot on the same night
you know I mean they're all [__]
coming coming at the at the fans out of
order
uh so me and Jan are when it comes to
the video
sales we're going to be hobbled because
it's
gonna be just us so there's we'll get
you've got to have it out there for for
street cred
but eventually you run out of ideas but
you know that's all right you
he also we can also get hired help too
through girls because really a lot of
money's in producing
your hiring Talent as shooting them as
and then you own that
that video and you sell it because
they're paid up front me and Jen
wouldn't be in it right see yeah
eventually like we're doing eventually
we get I mean like I said I do want to
do we have like ours yeah but I do
um eventually want to get to a point
introduction well if we're making money
we could like hire someone else to do
all this to do them we just handled
Direction
uh fronting the money for the production
and then doing editing and graphic
design touch up
that's
you know photo touch-ups and [__] and
that's the that's really where the money
is but you have to have a lot of
liquidity
you know you wanna you wanna have about
five thousand dollars liquid at all
times
making all that because it's going to
get hung up it's a bit paying people
rent and stuff expenses well and I was
saying the expense I mean honestly it's
just kind of like when starting out like
I said I'm doing we're doing this
because it's like it sounded like fun
like it was something that I wanted to
do and so I kind of feel like for as
long as we can
you know do it and I think that um
I would rather not involve other people
because at first because I just feel
like it's going to be drama and expense
and [__] like that so it's like Mitch
easier just me and you because like you
know we don't need other people like
yeah messing up the [__] and like
getting their egos getting in the way
yeah yeah Bill brought up you brought
out a lot of good things he said that I
can
because of our skill sets we're [__]
gold mine we have production and editing
[__] skills you know so I don't have
to write so I don't have to farm yeah
Farm any of that out I can do all of
that myself all you gotta do is just
[__] have a location
and higher actors and we got the
equipment you just shoot it and then you
pay them and you own it and you sell
that
so that's just production a studio
project another another Advantage is
that it's got you in it you're female so
recruitment for females a lot easier
because most of these companies are just
owned by single males
and a lot of women don't want to work
with them they don't know that dude you
have to yeah I mean you can't blame them
it's like you know he's a [__]
creeper yeah
so now you know I already have Bill said
he'd already back us because and he's
all that shit's done over Twitter and
he's got like 70 000 subscribers so he's
gonna send seventy thousand at us when
we're ready
all right and then
also he knows everybody every all he
knows all the talent that's working in
this area
so as long as long as they're tested and
[__] they're hired we can shoot
anything with them yeah we don't have to
be in it at all
just shoot it right and edit it front it
but
it already picked his brain it takes
about six months unless it's really good
content it takes and it just hits it
takes about six months to make your
money back yeah well that makes on a
video yeah
but promotion matters too it's a lot of
stuff granther says the first live
stream will y'all be nervous
uh no I probably not I don't I don't
really well because the thing about it
is that you don't have to do anything
you don't want to do yeah one you don't
have to do anything you don't want to do
um two it's not like you're in a room
with actual people looking at you like I
know that there's actual people looking
at you in reality but you can't see them
you know what I mean and we we're kind
of the kind of people that don't really
care yeah that too yeah and the only
people that could see anything that
happens in private are people that paid
right and uh if you watch how things
happen on stream it's usually one person
at a time
yeah now there's a bunch of different
ways to do it
it would take you know it would feel a
lot like you could do gold shows where
you could promote the show is going to
start in about an hour you can do a
countdown down and everything
and you say you know for 500 gold which
is 500 bucks we're gonna do a half hour
show in the show this will happen this
will happen and this will happen
once the 500 you know if the 500 is met
and the time we can start the show we
can wait till the countdown to con count
and uh once the show's going people can
buy in too to see it
you can leave all those options open you
can't see them
so that's guaranteed money you've
already been paid
you know you've already been paid 500.
to do that show and they're watching it
yeah and that might only be [__] 10
15 people you can't see them yeah and um
you can see comments they can tip during
the show two makes us making suggestions
just [__] yeah but like I said you don't
have to follow their suggestion just
necessarily because like well streamate
and like a lot of the platforms I think
too they have just like a menu of things
like you know if you tip this much then
you can ask for this so you can't just
like ask for random [__] and like expect
people to do it yeah it's not like
[__] kinky ass ChatterBait where
you're in on that channel you're having
sex in public man there's ten thousand
people watching you and only [__] 10
of them are paying
yeah you made 500 bucks but [__] 10
000 people saw it
yeah and they didn't pay right it's not
like that it seems quantity or equality
to see anything you have to pay yeah
which seems much fairer yeah that way
you're not being used I mean some people
might like that better like some people
don't really seem to not care but
I don't know I've I've watched a couple
like recorded ChatterBait streams yeah
you know of various people whether it
was solo female or couples or solo male
or whatever
and
um they basically I mean the one that we
watched the other day I mean she's just
sitting there just doing [__] you know
like sticking stuff in her butt and
everything like that and like nobody and
she's just trying to like entice people
to like stay in the room like stay in
her room were you talking about uh the
one dressed like Wilma film no no the
girl with the ears and the she had like
pink hair I don't remember I don't
remember that one yeah she had like pink
hair and like little like furry ears
yeah
but yeah they're wearing costumes and
[__] yeah yeah
cause like you got to change it up well
that's see that's what Tammy was saying
and said she can't can't you redo one of
your bedrooms as a studio and she says I
would start buying cheap Decor so I
could change it up every so often yeah
we're gonna actually we have [__] set up
over there yeah where it's just kind of
like you know we have pillows and the
curtains in the background it's all
satanic yeah it's a it's a cool
background like we took some photos and
stuff with that too okay ring lighting
coming yeah we're gonna order some ring
lighting and also we were thinking too
about eventually like expanding the
videos out it's like you know we could
do some [__] outside we could do you
know if we don't get arrested we gotta
find a funny where to go wait oh you do
okay you found a place yeah and there's
all kinds yeah there's all kinds of
stuff for places where motorcycles can
get okay that's again the cameras and
equipments are small everything's
portable
okay yes it's daytime
we were thinking about he's like oh we
could do something in the car too but my
car is so [__] gross and filthy yeah
I'd probably have to clean it before
it's like oh man I gotta clean this
[__] thing I wouldn't worry about
that kind of [__] there's so many other
things that have to happen first before
it yeah yeah that was just like
something there's so many holes we have
in the market for
of the selection that we have now
I mean just just a solo genre
you can get 30 or 40 videos out of that
just solo
basically variations of [__] that you
already did yeah and
she has a different outfit yeah it's
different yeah the settings
different the [__] themes different
and you can um you can you can do five
of those a day
murder Hornet said uh wow how this show
evolved LOL uh also get some shag carpet
no because then we gotta vacuum it yeah
and like there's also a misconception
about streammate and all that stuff is
that it's just wall-to-wall sexual
activity is not most of the couples that
are doing stuff it's talk show like this
yeah well like I said we've said that
before that it seems like a lot of it
just seems like 90 just this like just
people shooting the [__] yeah with the
people in the chat
um you know but then the other 10 is
maybe some [__] will go down yeah and
you might be on there for a couple hours
and you might make three or four hundred
bucks and it's because doing the show
and all of a sudden go hold on gotta go
private and the screen blacks out right
because somebody's [__] asked for
something you didn't see it because they
could send secret comments to the to the
people so you can be back there
negotiating and cutting a deal and then
five minutes later you get back that
dude's trying to [__] save money he
shows up dick in hand
and he's ready to go he see he's trying
to get his [__] done with it about five
minutes so then he goes back public
after that well you set the the the
price per minute you know 5.99 per
minute 6.99 per minute
and um
so you get paid for that time the thing
is is that stream mate because you have
to pay for the platform they take 65
percent yeah it takes it but it's worth
it because they're screening all the all
the customers
the customer can't even talk to you
unless they have your credit card
numbers
yeah so you can't even go in there if
you don't have any money
yeah because they don't want a bunch of
freeloaders yep which like I said we
don't want that either yep
um thank you very much granthers for
giving us a Super Chat best of luck with
the new Endeavor I'll actually know some
real porn stars
we're not a porn stars
big difference between us and a porn
star
we're considered pro-ams or Pro that's
what they call it Pro-Am man yeah a Porn
Star Wars they work for
Studios
and they got [__] amazing body counts
because they have to [__] work
every [__] day and they're not really
controlling what they're doing
they gotta [__] a lot of people that's
not us you know yeah I'm like nothing
yeah no thanks I mean if some people are
into that that's cool but it's like I'm
not it's not really my thing those
those girls they'll [__] they'll make
them burn through 200 dudes a [__]
year two 300 dudes a d a year
yeah there's a second
that's inhuman man
I I I couldn't do that and I'm a man
yeah I couldn't go through 200 women
[__] a year and in a [__] in a
[__] assembly line factory
process
it had become a drag real quick
yeah I could see that I mean because
like like I said you show us it works
you have to do it yeah it's like your
job and it's like if you show up and
it's like what if they come up with some
like real like [__] sketchy ass [__]
that you don't really want to do you
know what I mean that you're not into
you can't really say now I've heard so
many porn stories when you know people
in there they got dudes that are hired
he's hired to [__] and he hasn't been
paid he's not they're not paying him
that much maybe three four hundred bucks
and he's got to do this scene
with this chick
if she's hot
but she's a [__]
[Laughter]
and it's in between cuts that get away
from me you know what I mean and then
the actions come on over here get it
hard you know that kind of [__] what the
[__] come on
bossy bossy bossy no no inkling no idea
what it's like for a man to maintain a
[__] hard on there's all kinds of you
know I mean they're just okay and then
cut okay get away from me She [__]
hates she hates you and she's she's got
to work with dude and she's just like a
diva talking on her phone all the time
you know in between looking at her phone
okay let's go you know they're just
there for the body yeah and that would
really [__] frustrate you you know
you get pissed off because you know
you're not being treated as a human you
think what's dehumanizing to the women
is it dehumanizing to those dudes oh
it's dehumanizing they're like everybody
well depending on what kind of porn it
is I've seen some like kind of nice
positive porn but it's just like a lot
of it is kind of dehumanizing yeah the
the the the the Pro-Am stuff is as long
as it's not mass production because some
of the like the stuff Bill does is kind
of mass production in a certain way
it's just a product they're just making
it out cookie cutter it looks real
[__] bizarre and extreme from the
customer's point of view to them they're
like working in the circus they're like
circus acrobats they don't have any
emotional
reaction to any of that [__] right there
it's just making money
um that stuff it can be
convincing
that's not real good stuff well if it's
convincing it's good because it's
selling all right yeah you can say that
but they got other [__] that's just
amateur stuff girls working alone in
their own homes and they mean the [__]
what they're doing
yeah because they're doing it because
they want to
you know what I mean I mean presumably
most of them could find other ways to
make money if they wanted to but they
were like no I'm gonna do this that's
why it's hard to beat those only fans
girls all right only if they got only
fans girls that are making a [__] ton of
money more than any porn star
they got porn stars that go to become
porn stars so they can become an only
fans girl and and bring all their damn
fans with them but they can make real
money on only fans and that's a more of
a
personalized product a lot less
demeaning those girls can make money
doing solo stuff and pretending to be
fake girlfriends it's a virtual
girlfriend yeah because the way only
fans are set up is each client only
interacts with the girl he can't see
anybody else he doesn't see the other
clients or anything and that thing's
[__] tricky it's like each dude is in
a [__] cell pointed directly at that
girl and she can put out Mass DMS and
it's all AI to make it looks look like
she's talking to you personally yeah
she's actually talking like
50 guys or 30 guys and these dudes stuck
in a lot of them think they have a
relationship with this girl because you
can ask me questions she'll respond
you know because that's her job is to
just run that social media platform only
fans but they're doing other platforms
too
but every day they'll go in there
and uh you know they'll send messages
and doodle [__] send her another 30
bucks for this or buy this or that she's
just out there
selling these videos
selling little services like to wake you
up in the morning
for a certain amount a week she'll
[__] wake you up in the morning at
certain times and it's probably AI just
who knows yeah because I'm like I'm not
getting up to wake up some Rando
oh yeah
it's probably expensive get an alarm
clock
yeah
[Laughter]
well dude thinks it's his girlfriend
yeah
Trey says uh this is just I would have
never guessed the show would take a turn
like this and I mean that in a good way
I don't know why you guys weren't paying
attention to it
you didn't pay attention
yeah that's the thing I mean I don't
know it's just it just seemed like I
said it seemed like kind of like a
logical
uh conclusion at least for us maybe I
don't know maybe we had the technology
to do it and uh just sitting there six
million dollar porn yeah we can do it so
why not
yeah like I said it's just an extension
of what we do here we already have all
the stuff
yeah
we had cameras we had lights we had
editing software yeah
Trey said I just thought you were
talking [__] when you'd say stuff like
that ah Tom
no he
got a lot of [__] but he was actually
serious all that [__] I've been talking
all these years [__] I'm going back
it up these nests have seen some of the
[__] he goes like damn dude you should
have been porn a long time
I said yeah thanks yeah yeah giving you
giving you credit requests dude dude I
know he's not gay or anything
[Laughter]
it's not just hype
hahaha
yeah Tom lives up to it yeah he lives up
too they're talking about
um when they first discovered the show
because Trey said how many other people
have been here since day one essentially
I found the show on like episode three
holy [__] that was way back in 2016 or
something like that that was a lot of
[__] man hopefully we've really been
doing this for seven years pretty mama
it's been that long I think it's been
almost seven years it's unbelievable it
seems like we just started
in a lot of ways it does yeah
I don't know it seems like a long time
but then it does kind of seem like we
just started too like at the same time
which is crazy it's funny you know what
I mean we got fans that help talk to
them personally you know like there's a
girl from
um Israel named aylet
and she's listens to all the old stuff
too
she'll send me a message asking a
question about something for [__]
five years ago and I'm like uh do we
even do a show about that I don't
remember this I don't remember yeah
we'll see the thing about it I think
about this too because holy [__] like
sometimes I'll go back I don't usually
watch our old shows
but sometimes I'll go back for example
and like read like a I don't know like a
book review or something like that that
I did like six months ago and I don't
even remember writing [__] I did six
months ago you know what I mean because
well the thing about it is that I
usually have so many projects going on
that it's like if I remember in every
detail about everything I ever did like
that's you know my brain would just be
stuffed full of stuff and I just
wouldn't have room for anything for any
new things so I think usually my brain
kind of like dumps everything after a
little bit empty in the garbage it's
like emptying the garbage out
because otherwise you know uh grabther
said grandfather arrived sometime it's
funny that Grimes are still talking to
himself and talk about himself in the
third person uh arrived sometime in 2019
when the pandemic had everything locked
down watching YouTube was all there was
to do yeah that's hard to believe that
was a long time ago yeah that was a long
time ago too
um yeah and Trey said uh it's like I
know you guys but still it's hard to
tell online if someone's being silly or
serious that's the thing because because
like I said Tom does a joke a lot yeah
so I you know and I've known him for a
long time but even I'm not entirely sure
like when he's being completely serious
and when he's not you know I mean it
might be a shade of gray I might be
joking around and kind of serious at the
same time I might be like uh mulling it
over like maybe I'll admit I might do
this or I might have to do this or right
you know sometimes I don't know
yeah that's what I figured yeah I
figured maybe you were just kind of in a
gray area where you didn't really know
if you were being serious or not but I
mean when you when you came because I
mean when I was talking about oh I
should like well we were talking about
oh I should be a dominatrix because I
you know if people would pay me to step
on their nuts then I'd be totally about
that like I wasn't completely serious
but then on the other hand but I
probably would do it yeah like if there
was enough money in it but then like
when Tom said why like don't even bother
doing that kind of [__] it's like why
don't we just [__] start live
streaming
like start making porn and stuff like
that and then we don't have to go any
place or like deal with anybody yeah and
he's like we already got all the
equipment and everything so we wouldn't
really have to do anything well the
first thing I did wasn't to live stream
porn right it was just to be to do
dominatrix stuff live
yeah I watched one she was great she was
from Romania and she had a similar
backdrop like that she's in a throne
with [__] statues of [__] bass
death and she's just
being firmed with [__] and then
just starts teasing them and [__] she
didn't do anything sexual really
and making money she didn't go private
though I don't and it says behind her on
a big sign this is not a sexual service
that made me laugh
I love that she had a side of the back
yeah yeah yeah yeah she was like [__]
straight man somebody talks some [__]
about her and she reached back and grab
like one of them big old black dildos
like Jenny Vaught right
she picked that up and she's looking at
the phone and she throws it on the
ground like that and then grabs the
[__] grabs the cam and points it at
the at the thing on the ground and she's
she had a nice wood floor hardwood floor
just kind of dark in here about this
lightning like that and she gets a
a squeeze bottle of lube you know like
oil and squirts it on that thing as it's
sitting on the [__] floor and takes
her shoes off of their [__] feet it
starts [__] rubbing that thing she's
describing what that feels like to you
you see I'm doing this on you and this
snitches going on and on you know it
just it was and [__] money
dudes are [__] tipping her and [__]
and she just did it with her feet
talking [__]
and then she told the dude to leave
the [__] out of here yeah
okay now you can go
like a Romanian accent yeah get out you
have to show me this girl I feel like I
would probably I could probably hang
with this chick
[Laughter]
mistress bastet mistress bastet I think
what it was
see that's pretty nice that was in her
name like I said I could do that kind of
stuff but I mean to be honest the videos
we've just made so far
um have just been like kind of more
standard stuff but I've actually had a
lot of fun doing those
they're kind of well you know what I
mean it's like it's kind of a pain like
like I said you know and I'm sure
anybody that does that films porn or
anything like that looks like it's like
not glamorous or anything like that
because you know
takes a long time to get ready you can't
do exactly what you would do if there
wasn't a camera on you because you're
like oh that angle doesn't look good or
whatever so it's like you're just
constantly worrying about that what
about technical issues with [__] right
right I'm going through all this going
man I'm going through all this [__] man
putting all this stuff for this I mean I
bet you I'm not on camera
is this cutting my head off then I'm out
in the front
I bet I'm out of the foreign
Jenny says something and I'm thinking
about she'll say something out loud
during the scene and I'm like I bet you
that microphone didn't pick that up
because that was awesome well we had to
do what we did with one with one video
that we shot which I I've already edited
together was that luckily we actually
shot it from two different angles like
we were shooting it with
um one small camera like kind of from
almost two tablets oh it's two tablets
yeah like that they were on um like a
tripod one was in my hand and then one
was like he would hold it and then I
would hold it yeah I hand it to it
so yeah so we have that and luckily
because in some of the stuff because I
was saying stuff but my face wasn't
facing the other thing and then when I
was holding the tablet it was kind of
like rubbing against the uh couch so it
was kind of making noise so we didn't
get the audio of that but luckily like
the the other tablet like picked up the
audio so I just pulled the audio out of
that and like laid it over the other
video so it actually came out really
good and it actually came together like
real seamless yeah I was like oh because
I was watching it I was like oh I'm so
proud of myself like it looks all
professional and everything like cutting
back and forth camera One camera two
camera one and I was like look at that
like even the audio lined up and
everything it was like it was pretty
good
that's pretty good I'm talking [__]
smacking that ass well see I ran her a
[__] tablet so take a picture of
yourself
send it to your other boyfriend that's
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah cause I talk
[__] during this time I was like I'm
gonna make a whole video based on that
premise yeah that you that you went out
for the night and I'm like sneaking
around yeah and stuff like because he
knows I would never do that it's awesome
it's all uh uh [__]
psychology right it's all psychology and
what it and then when Tom watched that
video that I made when he wasn't there
he just thought that was the most
awesome thing yeah right he's like a big
confidence boost I'm sorry yeah it's
gonna be good
she's already [__] with me
and she's [__] having [__]
outtakes and getting mad going God damn
it well you know how I get when I can't
why are you so mad I'm talking to the
camera why you so mad don't just do it
over yeah
well you know how I get like because I
hate hate having technical issues I mean
I look I'm the kind of person where it's
just like one I'm super impatient I've
just always been like that that's just
the way I am and I'm sorry but I figure
I pay good money for like computer
technology and like all of this
high-tech [__] and it better [__]
work so if it doesn't [__] work I'm
gonna get really really irritated yeah
it's
funny because he's
happened was that I shot
um it was probably like four or five
minutes and then I was like [__] that
I'm starting over because I kept having
um all kind of technical issues and he
wasn't here like to help me so I was
just yeah he was out at bike night so
then like I did a couple other ones and
then it's funny because like the end of
it everyone I'm just like God damn it
you know what he was just like laughing
at me like all my little outtakes in
there like dildos falling over and I'm
like oh [__]
one of the solo things that I filmed is
just her [__] blowing rubber [__]
dildos all right it's hot though she got
her in this outfit it's a sexy [__]
dress that is too [__] small for her
she's just [__] bulging out of the
top of it it looks it's it's a little
small yeah yeah women would think it's
highly unacceptable dudes are like yeah
that's the way a dress should fit hell
yeah I wanted to wear that [__] to the
club and I was like I would be so
uncomfortable on wearing yeah like it
fits but it's just I mean the top of it
is very very very very tight she's
spilling out over the top I even got
like muffins I got a good shot of the
[__] boob muffin coming out flexing
back in I know he kept going around one
side yes that thing is so big it's so
[__] big
you know she don't know she's a woman
you know what I mean [__] dude no I
know I get it dude that's just [__]
like oh that's something you want to see
but you don't see in the wild you know
what I mean you don't see in the wild
you don't see it in the wild right so I
got it on camera I saw it in a while all
right and uh she's sitting there [__]
blowing these things she's doing a
[__] great job you know what I'm
trying to get the angles right I'm just
walking around trying to kind of keep
from casting a shadow on her because the
way the lighting was we were using
[__] lighting the colors came out
real good though everything's real Vivid
red red red red [__] wig and the red
background looked all satanic
and uh she's doing a good job just
getting all in and all of a sudden her
[__] wig starts Watching God damn it
[__] way
it wasn't falling off it just it went no
it went in my mouth like the hair went
in my mouth like along with the dick she
[__] lost it and I was like [__] yeah
yeah and I was like thinking I was like
God damn why would I want to kill God
damn I want to keep that in this video
but he was trying to get me to keep it
in there yes I'm like I don't think we
should keep it yeah I said it's gonna
break character yeah like I get that
it's funny what we could do actually is
yeah I was gonna we could do like a
blooper reel that would be really funny
like some people might be into that like
I don't know how hot that is but later
though that's what I'm saying because it
kind of demystify the video
yeah when you see
I watch porn
now
uh you know well actually since I've
been [__] talking to Bill and hanging
out because we haven't played in this
for a while I watch porn now and mostly
when I'm focused on is what camera is
this what's the camera angle how many
[__] camera angles were at happen
right oh I saw that looking for tips
yeah so I saw it I saw her she was
blowing a dude and all of a sudden there
was a fade and she's blowing him so what
happened so I know what it is she said
get that thing out of my mouth you know
they cut something out of there anyway
so I'm seeing where it was patched
together they're all patched together
you just don't notice it
yeah they're patched together products
and
they're breaking character and laughing
and then have to cut that out there's
all kinds of [__] going on like I said
sometimes their hair goes in their mouth
along with the dick that's it right so
you might see something that kind of
like emotionally [__] set you off
you're like man that looked kind of
[__] brutal or whatever you know or
man I don't think she I don't really
think that [__] that chick really
wanted to go down that way or something
now this shit's totally artificial you
read it into it too much it was
those people know each other they've
been they rehearse the whole thing
beforehand they tell you we're gonna do
this this and this okay sounds good
nothing is spontaneous you can't do
anything in spontaneous because the
costumes and the lighting and everything
has to [__] agree to this you know
what I mean [__] you have no you
can't just say like spontaneously go
anal that's just got to be planned right
or there's gonna be a [__] unhappy
people okay there's gonna be some
unforeseen well not unforeseen
circumstances yes we're seeing
circumstances
yeah
yeah it's not gonna look good or smell
good
on camera so this there's nothing
spontaneous about anything yeah Tammy
said just like regular movies exactly
yeah just exactly yeah I've heard
[__] dudes in the red pill Community
you know [__] uh these guys I just
totally understand it they don't want to
date porn stars but they come out and
say that's not at work no they don't
know anything about theater what are you
talking about [__] yes it is yeah so
that's not real why don't they go do it
and then they can come back and cry
about how not work it is um
you know except they probably wouldn't
be the Raptors went to little drama
school together we were both [__]
good we got real drama trading from a
[__] great teacher and and a few of
our friends [__] actually became
celebrities you know like [__] Mary
Lynn and stuff
um
no shooting that [__] is the same as it
is theater
a lot of the same problems with theater
it's blocking basically mixed with
[__] acrobatics and it's psychosexual
um do you really have to do that this
you know what I mean like they are
really doing that
but there's pausing and chain and
changing things and [__] going now
that's not working we'll try something
it's very artificial
um
it doesn't it doesn't emotionally or
physically feel like regular sex either
it's uh more like very extended foreplay
but you're thinking about other things
too like it's fun I'm not saying that
but it's like not like yeah quite the
same not quite the same yeah oh
for me not as satisfying because I'm
worried about other problems now
they say that you kind of get used to
that once you've mastered all the little
[__] technical issues and everything
yeah we're still kind of like on the
learning curve at the moment right that
it can be a little bit more natural
that you can get into a little bit more
but
the thing is when you're doing it that's
not what you're thinking about the thing
has all been planned out you know what
you're going to wear you know what the
video is going to be about who it's
going to sell to what has to happen in
it uh everything's all been discussed
about what you're gonna wear how hard or
easy it is going to be take to take off
what the camera angles are going to be
so there's no spontaneity it's not like
normal sex at all yeah
uh uh your your manufacturing a product
wow okay a product is a stale way to to
[__] put it you're performing you're
you're making a you're making an artwork
that you're gonna sell yeah it's a video
artwork you're gonna it's erotic art
yeah be a good way to yeah
and that's like we're not being
facetious I actually do think that it's
like yeah you know now some of the
shit's tacky but tacky is part of the
art for certain things that they're
doing and a lot of it I would want
nothing to do with right
um
a lot of that [__] I would want nothing
I don't want nothing to do with the
gangbang
because that's just punching dudes stand
around beating it waiting their turn and
[__] that that [__] I would feel [__]
out of place and tacky as a [__]
doing that [__] yeah like what am I yeah
and then some girl who's sucking
pretended to enjoy it but really she's
just there for the job and she's just
waiting for this to be over she's
[__] going like yeah another another
two I gotta go pick my kids up from
daycare you know after these 18 dudes
yeah another man yeah another two hours
[Laughter]
seven more loads to swim
okay that's what I mean well like I said
I know some people are into it but yeah
the customers are more into it uh yeah I
do kind of feel like well and like we
said we've talked about that before I
don't really I mean I I never really
like watched a lot of porn because it's
just not I mean generally like women
don't watch a lot of porn
but um you know I could be wrong about
that maybe they watch more of it
nowadays than they used to but um just
you know lately watching it like I said
just getting tips and ideas and stuff
like that like I said camera angle
scenarios and stuff like that yeah so
we're like watching it for that for
ideas and stuff and I'm just kind of
like a lot of it
I don't know a lot of it I don't really
like because for that very reason
because it comes across as very
artificial and also I just get the sense
that I can't I can't really get into
porn where the women look like they're
not having a good time yeah if the women
are super into it and look like they're
having a good time yeah then that's
that's awesome to me that's why I tend
to prefer like more amateur porn and
stuff like that because I said this is
you know these are people that are
actually a couple or actually you know
what I mean so they are a real I mean
they would really be having sex even if
it wasn't on film and so that is more
appealing to me than just somebody that
got paid to be there and it's like I
don't even [__] know this dude you
know yeah that's like yeah and you can
tell when people actually know each
other
yeah in the amateur board they're
getting along well get along a lot
better you could tell they're more
comfortable they're like you know the
[__] shady shade arrays you can see
her on [__] YouTube or not YouTube uh
what do you call it um
Instagram
she's a Pro-Am and it's just her and
other friends of hers that are built
like her she's overweight with him
Brazilian butt lift and a little bitty
waist and big boobs and she's cute
remember I was tomorrow oh yeah is that
the one you were showing me yeah yeah
okay it's basically her and her friends
roll around on the bed
um shaking booties
uh making out
very limited sex between them like oral
sex
and but but Shady doesn't have sex with
any dudes yeah she'll just be in the mix
helping right but if you pay attention
she doesn't touch anybody except the
girl yeah which tells me she's married
yeah and she's or she's not into dude or
she's not she's married
she's married but she's being hired as a
[__] a high-end extra
she's just in the shop
you know yeah so they have a lot of that
they're they're
um
pro professional amateurs though and
then the couple that's having sex if you
probably looked into it that's probably
the chick's husband
yeah so it just but it just all depends
on the video
she's looking at me yeah what's Pookie
up to she's right there why is pokey up
to you but you can tell when uh
uh it's like like I said it's hard for
the studios to beat only fans because
they got some girls in there that are
smoking hot
working in their house in their bedrooms
doing strip teases and dancing and
[__] playing with toys
but they're into it because it's just
them yeah nothing's bothered never
recording it
yeah like I said there's no in their own
room they got like some music on they
like they're just like you know they're
just performing for the camera and you
can tell they're enjoying themselves
like they like to do that so very hard
for a professional studio to [__]
compete with that
because he it's hard to compete with
somebody that isn't punching a time
clock
yeah it's somebody that's doing it by
their own choice right and she's doing
it for
fans that she knows of they're on her
only fans right
so yeah like you said it's to me that's
like a lot more enjoyable watching
something like that than watching kind
of like more
some of the [__] that's meant to be
overwhelming I guess as a some some
dudes like [__] that's extreme
you know what I mean like I always
[__] thought gangbangs were [__]
tacky tacky as [__]
yeah and they're difficult to [__]
film if you pay attention to what's
going on because if it was a natural
game it'd just be a cluster of dudes you
wouldn't even be able to see the girl
right they're not line them up so they
end up with a bunch of dudes like
they're waiting for an ATM
in the background and you you see that
[__] like
I'd hate to be that dude right there man
he's like number eight because you know
he's got a long time before he's gonna
get up there he's just got to sit there
between two other dudes so I can pull on
it pretend like he's [__] rocked up
hard and I'm looking like a number it's
soft man so that I feel you bro
tacky as [__] this dude's been knocking
need [__] what do they call
them uh [__] mopes yeah mopes they're
[__] porn extras they're just
vitaminer Barrel dudes you know bad
shape guys and
stand around waiting for the gangbang
yeah yeah
like they're waiting for an ATM machine
yeah
stay in the line of McDonald's or
whatever
pretended like this isn't all normal
director told me to do that
it's [__] funny it is yeah and uh
it's this shit's so [__] funny it's
hard to believe that some people would
[__] be offended
I can because it's definitely obviously
the whole thing's just a [__]
orchestrated setup yeah you know what I
mean there's nothing normal about it
nothing natural about it just some fake
[__] that suddenly drift up that they
wanted to film yeah I mean you know like
pretty much all of it is so yeah I mean
nothing wrong with that like I said
they're you know like sometimes it's
good like Sammy said they're like
regular women yeah yeah but
which are also fictional yeah and
they're you know meant to entertain you
just like porn is meant to entertain
just you know entertain your genitals
that's what that's why
but
it's the same otherwise now would I date
or marry a real porn star woman no no
an amateur
some chick doing only fans yeah
yeah
sure why not she's not
being run through on [__] camera you
know what I mean
for a living and
600 dudes [__] a year type of deal
you know no she's just she's just okay
and probably getting cynical as [__]
about it yeah her psychology is going to
be [__] difficult to deal with and so
but no she's a [__] just some only
fans [__] jack off artiste chick yeah
yeah sure why not we were watching that
girl that um I don't remember what her
name was but she she did a video it was
like a live stream or something but um
she did it in her room as Wednesday yeah
like she had a really good Wednesday I
think her name is I think her name I
think her name is Mia yeah she's cute
and uh yeah she's yeah she's really she
can dance yeah she's like dancing there
she's all gosched out and whatever yeah
the thing that amazed me the most was
that [__] giant dildo she had a man
she just she swallowed that whole
[__] thing yeah like a sword
swallower and she was uh I was like
she's been practicing petite chick yeah
she's little uh she I could tell she was
a trained stripper though the way she
was dancing yeah she had stripper moves
for sure yeah she know what she was
doing and uh she could sit on her desk
and [__] lift her leg up put her
[__] foot straight up in the air with
perfect form and stuff and
had the braids and then she ends up on a
damn couch with toys
and did her dang and that was for a live
stream I think it was for a gold show
yeah I think that's what it was and she
hardly talked I know she's saying yeah I
don't think she said a single word no
she was singing along to that crappy ass
music yeah she had crappy ass music and
that was the only thing
[Laughter]
it sounded like something from like a
Japanese video game from the 1990s yeah
or something and I was just like oh my
God those [__] music is terrible but
yeah but yeah it's like now that I'm
thinking about it I don't think she said
a single thing no which is crazy it was
a gold show yeah
well that's what I said that I said I
said
your big skill is that you can act a bit
and you can write dialogue and come up
with ideas a lot of those girls not a
lot of them can't
that is one thing I noticed like well
because I mean the market is like super
saturated for sure like a lot of people
are doing it because you know there's
not much barrier for entry you don't
really have to have all you need is a
phone really or like a you know a laptop
a camera and you can go up there and do
it
and so you're gonna have all these
people doing it and like just watching
all the people doing it some of them are
really good at it and like they have
like different uh costumes and like you
know they have personalities and stuff
but a lot of the girls are not really no
I mean yeah I mean a lot of them are
like really beautiful and like they have
cool outfits and stuff like that but a
lot of them don't really talk or they
don't really
you know they're not really entertaining
or gregarious like in other yeah they're
not personalities right and and the ones
that usually aren't talking it's a good
thing that they're not because
chances are their personalities are not
attractive so you know it's better they
say nothing and you just leave a
Mystique there
that particular girl we were looking at
if she probably talks too much he
probably would like yeah she's [__]
dumb
I just now I just want to smack her yeah
she's like she's boring but she could
dance that was a stripper so she could
and she she could dance and move real
well and that that was her
skill and I guess if she worked as a
stripper it's like you don't really have
to talk they don't talk strippers don't
talk so that's probably what you think
they talk when they're off stage and
they're working the crowd
um but if you ever listen to any
there's all kinds of videos
about how to make money as a stripper
and most of the girls make money off the
stage because they got a lot of game
they can talk money out of a guy's
pocket yeah and a lot of the real
beautiful girls
that you think you'd be making all the
money or not making all the money it's
what it's more like one of the girls in
the middle that's real accessible that
has a lot of friends in there that come
see her and she knows how to talk to
guys and
how to get them to open up their wallets
basically well sometimes
um women that are super super hot are
intimidating and they so they kind of
like frighten dudes I kind of feel like
it's better to be like not like the
hottest but maybe like the second or
third hottest
the term intimidating because it puts it
in a different light it's not exactly
what's happening
guys aren't in general intimidated by
women
um I mean even a weak man like Gary
Ridgway killed like [__] dozens and
dozens of them they're not physically
intimidating you don't care if they
don't like you or not that's not what it
is
what it is is that sometimes you look at
a real beautiful woman and if she acts
aloof you're like yeah she's a [__]
it's not that sheer intimidated buyer
you just think she's a snotty [__] I
don't want to deal with her you know
what I mean and that's what happens a
lot with the real good looking ones the
real good ones are kind of snotty
so sometimes yeah so they don't
they don't because they can be because
they can't well they're snotty on the
street and you put them in a strip club
and then all of a sudden they're still
snotty and they expect dudes to just
throw money at them for how they look
that's not how a strip club Works a
gentleman's club
those dudes mostly want to socialize
to you know they
that's a sucker's game I mean it's like
going to the casino and playing [__]
uh slot machines you're gonna [__]
lose all your money you know but maybe
they're having a good time I mean that's
kind of like their social outlet I guess
I mean we go to golf clubs and drink and
dance to
dance dance to goth Rock but you know
and maybe some dudes just really enjoy
going to Rachel's and having a steak and
watching somebody Rachel's is different
though yeah Rachel's is not typical
Rachel's has good food and [__]
it's kind of classy it's kind of classy
yeah women can't go there unless they're
with a guy
so again me and Jenny went [__] Jenny
had a good time oh we got to go to
sweethearts this weekend maybe we'll go
[__] stop off at [__] Rachel so
we'll get a steak in there get a steak
at racist well yeah cause Rachel's is
right across the street yeah yeah that's
what I was gonna love her
like I said I kind of feel like
strippers are like hey Ryan woman yeah
yeah
um you know what I mean
but uh yeah that's what I was gonna say
because tomorrow we're gonna do like a
little shopping trip I didn't even know
there's this place in Casselberry which
is a suburb of Orlando and it's called
sweethearts with a z
and it's basically like the stripper
clothing store right I mean they have
like other kinds of clothes in there too
but it's mostly for strippers and yeah
and it's right across the street from
Rachel's like so a lot of the strippers
that you know they got like the big
platform shoes and you know like all
skin tight kind of stuff and everything
like that that's more nice
um yeah I wouldn't mind a little bit
more alcohol in there too
but um
we used to go there
um back when Tom still lived in
Altamonte Springs because it was pretty
close and because they you know they if
you have I mean you know if you have big
boobs that's pretty much like the only
place you can go and get like
like tight-fitting shirts that like are
flattering because like I said if you go
to like Walmart or Target or something
like that and buy something that fits
over your boobs then the rest of the
shirt is going to be baggy and it's
gonna be like a big tent and it's gonna
make you look like a [__] mile wide
so you have to go and get some [__]
that's like you know fitted
so um you know so so I would go to
sweethearts and get stuff there so I
have like a bunch of like nice shirts
and all and leggings and stuff like that
and some shoes and [__] like that that I
got there we hadn't been there for years
and years
and I honestly thought it had probably
closed because I didn't hear anything
about it but then we were talking about
and I said maybe we should check and see
if that place is still there because
it's like I could use uh you know some
more outfits and stuff for the videos
and I looked it up and lo and behold the
place is still open so we're actually
because I have a little bit of extra
money this week so
um so tomorrow we're gonna make I mean
it's kind of like a half hour drive from
here now but so we're gonna make like a
little Excursion tomorrow and see what
they got and see if I can like get some
new outfits and some new accessories and
stuff like that and uh yeah and then I
would say it's funny because I thought
the same exact thing I said Rachel's
right across the street I bet Tom's
gonna want to go over there hey let's go
over to Rachel's devastated
like we'll go there like Saturday
afternoon see what kind of who you want
to go during the afternoon they got the
afternoon shift that's when those girls
are [__] they're miserable because
it's slow in there right you know it's a
[Laughter]
with the strippers
I've heard the food there is good I've
never eaten there I've been there before
but I've never I never got food there
we just went like I said we went one
night because
um
uh our regular goth club back then venue
13.
um the bartender there his name was
Hector he was doing like a bartender
versus bartender competition like they
were having this whole competition where
they would pit two Bart two kind of
famous bartenders like from different
clubs in the city like against each
other and so they'd each have their own
little fan base like come and cheer for
them and blah blah so we were there it
was us and a bunch of our you know kind
of goth people friends
uh and we all went to like support
Hector because Hector was awesome and
I'm sure he's still awesome wherever he
is now
I haven't seen him in a while
but uh yeah the man and the strippers
were so happy they're like oh my God yay
like a bunch of cool weirdos you know
what I mean because a lot of them are
like into goth and [__] too so they were
like very very happy that all of us were
there and just hung out and like talked
to us like I said I had I had them all
like telling telling me all their
problems and
all and other kind of stuff it was super
funny that was yeah that was a fun night
that was a fun night man we got so
[__] hammered yeah
wow did you fall asleep in the car did I
fall asleep in the car I don't remember
no I made it home we did make it home
yeah we must be boring as hell man
everybody's leaving did everybody
everybody left everybody left pretty
much there's like five people in there
oh no
sorry everybody
[Laughter]
we could always change the subject if
you all want to
well I didn't like I don't see um what's
the last uh what's the last um chat
message that you have because I had a
chance I thought that nobody um oh uh
grandpars said best of luck
well that was no that was a long time
ago okay Tammy said I'm still here okay
yeah yeah cause I was gonna say I hope
you're all coming back all right so
someone came back I hadn't seen any new
chat for a long time so I thought like
something was going wrong wrong with the
streamer but he was like man [__] this
[__] we're out of here yeah
but you know what I mean I'm having a
good time it's Friday night yeah like I
said I was like so like Okay so
I'm looking forward to
three day weekend right yeah it's mine
for Monday
and I was thinking to myself all day
today while I was at work I said you
know what I said I'm gonna be so happy
like to leave this [__] place at 4
30.
um you know it's Friday and I get a long
weekend and all this other stuff and I
said to myself I bet some [__] up [__]
is gonna happen on the way home so I
don't get home on time and lo and behold
I got stuck in a traffic jam there was a
wreck about 20 miles
from my house
and I was stuck there for probably
almost half an hour
because I didn't get home until almost
six
and I don't even know like the wreck I
didn't even see the wreck I know it was
a wreck because I saw um like the
ambulance and stuff like going by and
the shitty thing was I couldn't go
around or like take a um an alternate
route because right at the um border
between Lake County and Volusia County
they're building an overpass and so the
old road it's just like two lanes and so
they have cones and cement and all this
other kind of stuff so it's you can't
really turn around or get out so we're
kind of just like stuck there so we're
just like sitting there for ages and
ages and ages and ages until they
cleared the [__] out and I don't even
know where the [__] was like by the time
I got up there I didn't know where the
[__] was or what happened or anything
it's weird because the ambulance came
like with all the sirens on obviously
but then like five minutes later it left
again but without lights on I was like
does that mean that nobody nobody was
hurt was hurt or the person was dead and
or what I don't know I guess nobody got
hurt because they didn't really seem all
that upset but you know what I mean
though but yeah so I was I was really
mad that I didn't get home so I was like
yelling in the car the whole way home
you know how I get yeah I get very
frustrated when things don't go the way
I want
you know how that is
what's up no no alcohol's starting to
hit me is it yeah I was sitting there
getting swapped getting quiet it's going
yeah yeah yeah
now Sunday night is we got two movies
yeah it's Sunday Sunday night okay
they're doing a special Sunday night
because everyone's off on Monday all
right so they're doing like an extra so
I guess we gotta go to that but
let me go get by the tablet real quick
let me check my bank account
oh yeah that's right because he would
get paid because it's a holiday weekend
so he probably got paid early
but yeah so I I don't know I'm looking
forward to like going to sweethearts and
seeing what because I haven't been there
in such a long time
I hope they have some good clothes for
me
but we'll see how it goes
but yeah they used to have a really cool
um
I got this great pair of shoes in there
I can't really wear I think I wore them
out one time and I regretted it but
they're super they're super cool looking
Tom loves them what's that those shoes
that I have that I got at sweethearts a
long time ago oh the uh the platform
ones with the spike heels yeah those are
just straight up [__] stripper shoes
yeah they're total sludgies yeah but
like I said I can't I could barely walk
into things I could barely stand in the
things you you wore those out on several
times no one time I wore them out one
time I wore them they wore you out I
remember you were like my feet and I was
like yeah I'm gonna be that [__] that
like takes the shoes off and like walks
to the car in her stocking feet which I
hate that you just uh
have problems with them because you just
your feet aren't broken
um that's what it is
you see that every night though if you
go clubbing you see at least one girl
carrying her shoes in her hand yeah at
home in stock and feet it's like these
shoes look super awesome but you just
have to wear them until they they're
they're easy you build up certain
muscles and your foot kind of [__]
changes and it breaks in the shoe a
little bit because they got girls that
can run in those and [__] dance and
[__] and those climb a [__] polls
it's just another skill
yeah it's just you have to suffer your
way through it
I've done enough suffering I can imagine
that because the ground is so far away
from you your ankle yeah the angle of
attack on the ankle got to be perfect so
you have to [__] get them
to place that thing down perfect yeah
because that's like a broken ankle yeah
right there and especially now that we
live in a house with stairs I can't even
imagine navigating the [__] staircase
in those things like I said I can barely
[__] stand up in them
without just sitting there like Bambi
like with my [__] legs shaking you
know what I mean you guys know what kind
they are man yeah they're just like
shiny black but they're just trying back
with a [__] really long story big
long stiletto here big platform kind of
a kind of just like an archetypical
stripper shoe yeah
I don't know if I necessarily I don't
know I need to I need to look and see
what they got at the at the store
tomorrow because we haven't been in such
a long time so I don't even know if yeah
and it's funny that bra came
yeah did you try it on I did it fits
better than the other one but it still
fits a little bit weird it might like
need some adjustment yeah is it but um
was it too tight around the rib cage no
okay that's one it actually that's what
see that's what okay so the first it was
just that thing was a a medium
that's what I mean it was like so weird
because all of the comments and stuff
like that or or the whatever said it's
like oh you need to get like a few sizes
bigger than what you would normally get
so I so we ended up getting what like a
3XL because of what they said and that
was way too big and then he bought a
medium and it fits then that fits just
fine yeah like I said it's still gonna
be
but yeah the band fits fine yeah like
but because it's like that weird shelf
bra it's gonna be like
yeah it's it's it's it's it's it's it's
one of those bras that goes around the
rib cage and it just cradles the bottom
of the breast right so everything's
exposed it looks good looks really good
she has another one I have another one
like that yeah but that's like the for
her body type and the the pierced
nipples and everything that's what you
want
yeah
I would kind of like I kind of wish that
they had one I'm sure that somebody
makes one like this somewhere that was
kind of like a whole like entire regular
bra with all the support and everything
but then like with just the middle part
where the nipple is cut out yeah they
got those because I feel like that would
work better than just like the shelfie
ones because the shelfie ones it's it
it's always kind of like a struggle they
got like maneuvering the [__] into like
the correct position
you know
so I feel like that would probably it's
just what looks best on camera that's
that's yeah well that's what we're
concerned about and like I said that's
what we're gonna be going to sweethearts
we have like a few things in mind like
okay we need particulars be there to try
them on that's the deal the deal it's
hard to buy that [__] that's why we're
going because it's hard to buy that [__]
on Amazon they'll have it but you don't
know if that exact that really is gonna
fit
because the sizes are crazy that's what
I mean it's like it's raw it's yeah and
that's one of the things is like I'm
always reluctant like I have bought bras
online before and it worked out but a
lot you know I bought some online too
that it's just like and didn't work out
yeah and because you know women know
their the sizes are not Universal
like there's no Rhyme or Reason To One
company's size eight yeah versus another
company size eight it's like they're not
the same like the measurements aren't
the same yeah like in China and Japan
and [__] they'll make they're making
those girls feel a lot better
they'll have a b cup they'll have that
labeled as Double D well that's what I
mean it's just kind of like a lot of
Asian like the sizing makes absolutely
no sense at all and we well I mean we
always know because for a long time we
would order those like a couple
companies in um you know in Asia that
made like these really cool goth clothes
but you always knew that you had to
order like three or four sizes bigger
than you would normally get because the
clothes it runs really really small I
mean you get like a large in like Asian
size and it's [__] tiny yeah it's
tiny yeah so it's like you know it's
makes you feel like a big fat whale
because they're always kind of like you
have to get like 3x or 4X because you
know no we really are bigger we are
bigger then well yeah I'm just saying
that
makes it makes us feel like super fat
like compared to them because it's like
that's a large over there holy [__] I
can't even get one leg in there
you should get large shirts from them it
was just a large men's shirt it was a
Chinese company and I get that [__] and
I feel like a [__] gorilla and that
was before
I don't know how [__] I'd be like an
extra extra large yeah over there extra
extra large they probably don't have my
size I had to get something stretchy
see that's what I was saying that's
another thing that's good about
sweethearts is that all their stuff is
stretchy yeah so it's kind of like one
size well one size fits most I guess
yeah which is good at least that's the
way it was we haven't been here in a
long yeah but like I said I didn't even
know it was still open so I was very
excited to know that it was like still
there but I guess they're getting all
the stripper business you know yeah so
because all the strippers are going
there do you see well it's not just the
strippers the strippers go there but a
lot a lot of Latina chicks go there yeah
that's true that's just like standard
latina booty girl [__] yeah it's not
like stripper strippers clothes like
someone is just like you know just
form-fitting dresses and stuff like that
that you could just wear out to clubs
women that have figures yeah
well like I said it's really good for
people with hourglass figures like big
boobs or like big butts or something
like that because
you know everything is kind of
engineered to be as flattering as
possible on as many body styles as
possible you know so yeah I've got like
a lot of stuff there
yeah Sebastian says there are some
Japanese Giants but mainly they are
small yeah I mean man some of the
clothes we've gotten there is like
[__] tiny tiny tiny especially I have
problem with like the pants the tops are
not too bad but usually I have to get
like a couple sizes up but like the
pants I usually have to get like four
sizes up we're gonna have any hips you
know right yeah and I do so
so it's always kind of a struggle but
yeah I mean ordering clothes online I
haven't had too much bad luck in that
regard but I'm always kind of like
afraid to I'm just like always afraid
it's not gonna fit right
you know so I'm kind of glad that we're
going there tomorrow so I can like
actually try some [__] on and
I hope they have some good [__] I was
like I said I've been there a few times
so I don't know I hope it hasn't gone
like the way of [__]
Hot Topic where it's like they used to
have like really good clothes and now
you go and they're like they don't have
anything there yeah and that's owned by
that woman yeah I know that's true yeah
it's been I feel like that place is like
an institution that place has been there
like forever yeah
you know what I noticed the other day
too when we were driving around is that
I thought I saw
didn't we pass Fairvilla
remember I said oh my God Fair Villa
like either moved way the [__] over here
or that's a second location I don't
remember where Fair Villa if you don't
know it's like that's also an
institution it's like a huge huge like
sex toy store yeah in Orlando yeah it's
all closed though too yeah they sold it
was massive it was like two stories yeah
it was a massive massive Place very
famous and it's been here as long as I
can remember
um but I've been there a couple times
I've got like some dresses there and
I've got like all kind of good [__] but
um
but I just I don't know we were passing
it and I saw it like in [__] I don't
know somewhere weird it wasn't Sanford I
can't remember where we were driving
where I saw it and I was like what the
[__] is that doing there so I don't know
if it's the second location or if they
moved it or
Tammy says uh you need to show us if you
buy anything cool oh I will I will I'll
do like maybe I'll do like a
a haul a sweethearts Hall if I if they
have anything worth we didn't take
photographs of it you put it up on uh
Instagram maybe oh yeah maybe that's a
good idea that's a good idea by the way
uh we have to start planning for a
starting a Twitter
once you start streaming you have to
have a Twitter
well I mean I do have one but I just
never go on there it has to be one for
the channel well I know but yeah well I
duh I have to do that for everything
like you know what I mean like it's
gonna be a whole if you give me the
password I can manage it
I mean I already can manage the Twitter
and stuff I already figured out
um
you know all the social media [__] that
I gotta make I already I made a logo and
I made all that
stuff yeah so well like I said I'm
pretty familiar with starting all that
because I have Facebook pages I have
Instagram Pages I've for all of my
different yeah stuff you know what I
mean
so it's just gonna be another one what
time is it
uh quarter to nine okay quarter to nine
all right how much longer do you want to
stream for well I don't know you seem
like you're kind of cranky and no I'm
not crazy
cranky I just start well not cranky
exactly but you know what I mean you
seem like you're not real
into it
no I would say that okay
I just I mean I just got a new drink
yeah we could drink all night though we
can watch movies and do whatever what do
these people want to do
yeah what are you guys yeah what you all
want to do
yeah we gotta watch um
Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels and
then we got that other one what was the
other one the uh snatch snatch yeah yeah
so we'll be talking about one of those
on Sunday yeah
that'll be the nice thing too is that
since I'm off on Monday
so we'll be able to
um
actually like watch The Haunting show
whenever we yeah want and then we can
maybe do the haunting show earlier I
mean you don't have to
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
we'll figure it out I'm just like so
excited that I'm that I have three days
off isn't that sad
[Laughter]
that I was like I was like so excited
about it
because I guess there'll be another one
coming up like because I guess we get
the Fourth of July off too but
you know
but let me see
yeah trees these are like really old
like nobody's commenting so I don't
really have like anything to they're
[__] sleeping everybody's we put
everybody to sleep everybody sleep
because everybody's off doing like
Memorial Day Weekend [__] yeah
yeah everybody's getting ready that's
what it is getting ready for Barbie
weekend man everybody a lot of people
are getting ready to go out
yeah
oh [__] we gotta make a Sheen run too
that's a [__] such a great app
yeah I mean there's so much good [__]
there for you like I said I'm gonna
well after we go to the store tomorrow
and we'll see see what they got what
they got so I can because obviously I
would like to get stuff that I can
actually like try on and [__] like that
first because priority is bra so you
just gotta see what kind of bras they
have maybe they have some cool stretch
pants like remember the pants that they
used to have down there yeah I got a
bunch of cool pants there there were
black pants and a head to [__] little
white stitching and [__] yeah yeah maybe
there's more stuff like that
maybe they have some of that [__] like a
five dollar almost damn [__] tight
stuff
they're all like tie-dye looking and
psychedelic colors and some of them are
kind of bell bottom you could use things
like that
yeah
it's just something you do use for a
photo shoot or just some scene or just
wear it around you know
but they have that on you on they have
that [__] on um yeah I have a lot of
those kind of like those kind of thick
stretchy pants that have like a little
bit of a bell bottom at the bottom I
actually found a bunch of those on
Amazon they're kind of like they're
listed as yoga pants yeah
um but they're actually I really like
them I have like a bunch of pairs like
that they're super super comfy you have
a bunch of them yeah you never wear them
yeah I do you do okay I just wore them a
couple days ago I didn't realize they
were beautiful okay there's a little
they're not usually hugely bell bottom
but yeah they're a little bit bell
bottom but yeah I have like three or
four pairs of those I think I bought
them all at the same time I wanted to
get some bright stuff with some patterns
and stuff too
Reds and well yeah I don't mind red but
the way that's what I'm talking about
what do you think I was talking about
yellow
yeah I thought you were gonna like put
me in some ugly Ash no no no
some ugly Normie [__] no
ice blue
um pinks hot pinks there's all kinds of
[__] that looks really good on camera
I do I mean I have some other I even
have some shirts that I got at
sweethearts that are I have one that's
um that's black and hot pink like
leopard print I have a blue and hot pink
leopard print yeah and I have one that's
like teal and dark gray like stripes and
I have a black and white stripe one with
like lace on the back get you some of
them fur leggings in the [__] animal
horn costumes and
you know they had all kinds of cool
little anime type little costumes yeah I
mean well it'll be good because we can
go and look at stuff because it might
give us ideas for like themes and stuff
yeah yeah now I I mean we do have an
idea for one
for at least one video that we want to
shoot this weekend hopefully we can get
more than one shot this weekend because
it's a long weekend step mom yeah we
still got to do that I was thinking
about that one the other day I was like
I think that'll be a good one yeah it's
gonna be called stepmom helps you with
your morning wood
I'm just laying there with a camera on
my [__] chest she walks in oh you go
you're up you know what I mean it's like
what's this
swallow that I
mean I can't be out with this don't tell
your dad
yeah it's gonna be over that's just
gonna be hands up it's gonna be a whole
thing yeah
I got all kinds of ideas Jay's like yeah
that'd be a good one just [__] crazy
bless you sweetie yes that was the
rubber oh okay I thought she sneezed
yeah but yeah it's gonna that that one's
gonna be funny like that if I can keep a
straight face we'll see
I think I've been doing good so far well
the funny thing about it is that you
would think because
I mean generally I don't you know I'm
kind of introverted
and shy and stuff like that but I don't
know for some reason like I'm not
nervous doing these videos I'm not like
the idea of doing like the live stream
is not nerve-wracking to me or anything
like that because it's not in public I
guess not there's not a big crew of
people it's just me and you or you by
yourself so it's a lot easier that's
true yeah
so yeah it's not yeah it's not weird I'm
not like weirded out well also you know
we've been
you know you've been doing this show for
seven eight years now so you know public
speaking is not your not not an issue
[__] me and Grandpa's [__] grew up
[__] performing in front of live
audiences and [__]
I got used to
performing you know be a watched it's
just it's just part of the game you know
and uh yeah let's try this out I don't
care I would not recommend this I really
would not recommend anything to do with
that industry
at the studio level if you were some
kind of single young female who wanted
to get married and I don't recommend it
that [__] well and especially and if you
maybe want to like have a career one day
or something like that I mean you never
know when it's going to come back and
bite you in the ass right because it
still will I mean even though there's
not as much of a stigma about it as
there used to be yeah um still you still
don't want like oh 10 years down the
line you're looking for a corporate job
and like somebody comes across your [__]
like on the [__] air if you're some
[__] 19 year old girl and [__] you
want to get married one day and you
don't want to you know no I would not
recommend it but you see when you start
talking about people who are over 30 or
over 40 and they've they're already
divorced they already have had maybe
have kids or they're in a relationship
they're married it's it's totally
different for people that are our level
of maturity you know it's not the same
yeah well that's the thing and like it's
just true of anything whether it's porn
or not I don't like being told what to
do and I don't really like so that's why
this kind of stuff appeals to me because
it's like you know we
can control our own thing we can just do
whatever we want like the way we want to
do it writing and [__] right like I
said and it's just me and you like yeah
we do this [__] anyway like when we're
here on film so it's just you have like
if you have some 18 year old girl and
you've jumped into one of those [__]
porn Studios or even one of these little
porn rings they're gonna eat you up yeah
they're gonna get as much as they can
out of you and uh that shit's internet's
forever
Tammy had to actually take me out of
grade it this is a great idea uh Tom
could be a Jehovah's Witness and he
comes knocking on Jenny's door who's a
Satanist and she converts him yeah
that's fantastic I like that idea we're
gonna have to do that yeah oh my God
that would be so [__] funny that'd be
so [__] funny whatever happened to
you remember do you still have this do
you remember how you had that kind of
like long
kind of priest yeah outfit you still
have that would it fit you anymore do
you think oh yeah I should because
that's that was super cool looking it
didn't have a priest collar on it but it
was kind of like it had a collar like
that classic yeah they had all kind of
bondage stuff on it but yeah yeah like
it had a bunch of like it was removable
though yeah it looked really cool on you
that'd be cool if you like wore that
although it doesn't really look like
Jehovah's Witness that looks more like a
cat yeah I was witness you just
Catholics don't go door to door as far
as I know no Jehovah's Witnesses they
usually destroy us like they just look
like the Mormons white shirt and a
[__] nameplate probably and [__]
gray slacks and [__] you gotta look real
lame and yeah you can have a bite we
don't even have a Bible around here do
we I don't know I don't have one
you could just have I mean you could
just carry some other bar I could find
some book they probably look like well
I'll give you Darwin's Origin of Species
there's so many other things we have to
do though there's so many others I know
but that's a great [__] idea I like
that idea a lot that would be super
there's a bunch of generic simple [__]
that has to be made
Tammy says I'll take my 10 in t-shirts
that is a great that is a great idea we
will eventually have to do one of those
because that could totally look like a
Satanist I have all kind of like shirts
with [__] pentagrams on them and
everything that would be super funny
I'm gonna convert you to satanism
I love it I love it
uh like yeah so if anybody else has any
good ideas like like I said it might
take us a while to get around to him but
that is a good idea yeah but we are
going to start out doing kind of like
you gotta do a bunch just your bit your
Baseline kind of basic stuff and then
we're gonna get into like the fun [__]
where we can kind of like I said dress
up in costumes and
do all that other kind of stuff like
cosplay kind of stuff that game is got
it's very Normy a lot of the stuff
thought it has to be leveled it just
real basic stuff that people are buying
and then once that's covered you can do
stuff just it just depends depends it's
I mean I guess it's kind of true of
everything but I'm always kind of
surprised how like not
not all that creative like a lot of the
stuff because you're like showing me
this one girl I can't remember her name
was but this one girl who what you know
what was she I don't remember what
platform it was either but she was kind
of like the one of the top ones or like
the top ten anytime about you're talking
about views what's your name black
something black
Lexi black I think what her name was
she was the one that was just her and a
bunch of dildos
that one no no he's talking to him no no
no it's not that not that girl like I
like that girl I'm just talking about
the one girl that all she did was just
she's just like
just sucked the same dick oh yeah yeah
that was and it was like the same angle
and the same and there was just like a
[__] ton of just videos like just like
yeah that was um the name of the channel
is uh
d-s-l-a-f that's the name of the channel
it's on
minivids
um the [__] that was
um
that was Bianca
okay her little thing she's got an only
fans all right it's called Bianca's
throat and all she does is just throat
stuff
doesn't have sex with anything nothing
and um
she's just some stripper and
there's a black dude that recruits out
of that strip club and he's got all
those strippers blowing him
and uh and he just got like a black but
it's kind of like a whole bunch of
videos just of that and she's the top
one they're very tasty though he's the
top it doesn't matter I know but I'm
just saying it's funny he's like the
number four channel on that or producer
on that platform
and uh all like all the top seven of his
videos are her
I saw her um what do you call it
only fans it's five dollars a month
what a bargain yeah
I'm just saying it's just it's funny to
me that she's giving it away you never
know exactly what the deal is that might
be a single mom
yeah
she's she's goofing around in it there's
outfits and stuff she said she doesn't
take any of this [__] seriously
and um
so you never really can't tell what the
situation I know she's a stripper oh
they're all strippers in that and she's
got pictures of herself in the locker
room where the strippers are and uh on
her Twitter
she's taken videos of herself on stage
in a reflection and a mirror on the
backstage
right so she is a stripper that's all I
know
and I don't know what city it is it's
probably Chicago
[Music]
the whole uh Jehovah's Witness and Satan
doesn't think John Gore says that would
be kind of like the storyline to the
devil's nightmare with Erica Blanc a
good movie
and then Sebastian said can I be the
Inquisition LOL
I just I just really like that idea I
think that's good I think that'll be a
good video that we can do one of these
days that would be fun
you know yeah after we get all the all
the basic [__] out of the way
but like I said
I do kind of I don't know I guess
because
I I you know I I want to make the videos
like
each of them different like I get that
we have to do
I'll like lay the groundwork and do all
the basic stuff and yeah and all that
kind of stuff but I do want each of them
to be like a different thing I don't
yeah but I'll be like no would you say
me I know how to do that right I know
how to do that
so
costumes that's the main thing costumes
lighting location same thing over and
over again
um
it's just different endings they're
they're it's generic
but the customer doesn't see it as
generic
you know they don't know exactly what
they're seeing
there's a formula to all that yeah
well I guess people that are like porn
connoisseurs you're just kind of like
going on there every day and like
looking for some well my friends the
producer
so he's telling me
yeah do this this this is saying that
the order he goes these sell well
because he knows it's just me and you
right so he's telling me what sells the
best if you're working with that just
just you or just me
and we've done we're part of them was
the the dildo ones of the solo that that
sells actually the best
in this situation yeah yeah better than
a couple scene yeah that'll do even
better
well you know we're just trying to like
cover all the bases because you have to
know who the customer is right and and
and what the rate of purchase is
so it's technical it has to do with
Market forces who the customer is why
why they about buy things I don't want
to get into it in front of everybody
all right [__] what is that I want to
buy anything that has any guy in it
that's competition
they want to eliminate all competition
they just want the girl
yeah I get that they're just jerking off
they they don't want anything to disturb
that
yeah I get it
Tammy says I got one for Jenny as a
librarian and Thomas needing help with
his research
that's also good the thing is though we
can come up with all kind of the thing
is though is that that in the modern
Market you can't go into that very much
that's very much 70s what you're talking
about you I don't know it's only the
trappings of that
work because they're not there for the
story
that's why video took over from film in
the 80s because the video just went
right to the now
um the [__] that's selling her [__]
five minute Clips seven minute Clips
there's no story there's no beginning
there's no end it's just a middle
and I've now noticed that remember that
girl you're talking about [__] uh uh
uh Bianca yeah it just starts there's no
beginning it's just it starts it's
already happening
it never quite ends it just stops right
you know
the dude never finishes there's no money
shot right because he couldn't
she wasn't that good
I guess
or they stopped it did a costume change
filmed another one and then filmed
another one yep
it went to the other side of the house
and filled another one
yeah and then they might have done five
I suspect that that's probably right
because like I said you got to maximize
because she paid for her the time you
hired her for that day yeah so it's like
yeah we gotta do we're gonna do five
right yeah each one will be 15 minutes
so if he gets a money shot at the end
it's gonna be a while before he can do
it again so yep yeah
that's the thing he can't just jump
right I see
I know what he's doing because we've
done it here so like oh okay that's what
he did
yeah yeah gonna have to like we made
four of them in one day right and it
cost him the same as making one I know
it's just funny it's funny that we have
to like think about that now because
it's like you know if we're it's days
where we're shooting a video
you know he's just kind of like well we
have to like stop doing this because
it's like what do you know what I mean
yeah like saves up this because uh this
is gonna go too good
so we have to like save it up yeah later
so we gotta stop and do something right
so I know what he's doing
you know he paid her [__] 700 bucks
for that day and [__] and so he got
five out of it or four
videos
yeah I mean that's the thing like we're
not spending a lot of money but we are
spending a lot of time like you know it
takes me like one or two hours to like
put all the makeup on and all the [__]
and everything like that and then get
everything set up and all that so we
definitely want to have at least
like some decent [__] footage I think
like the one that we shot
the best one that we shot so far like I
think ended up being wasn't it 12
minutes or 13 minutes or got that
something like that yeah once it was
once it was trimmed once it was trimmed
down like yeah we had we had like 30
minutes worth of footage but we trimmed
out a lot of stuff because a lot of it
was just kind of like
talking about what has to happen talking
about what's it's like oh what's the
angle here and stuff like that so we cut
a lot of that stuff out but fluff it
fluffing yeah like me changing positions
and [__] like that but although some of
the stuff like I said I did like some
funny it's not hilarious hilarious but I
did kind of like edit some [__]
especially that one part where you
turned and looked at the camera and I
was like oh my God that's too funny yeah
so I'd like zoom in on your face yeah
like so I just like a close-up where
he's like dead I was like oh my God
that's Larry and it's like every time I
watched it like I laughed again yeah I
was like
uh but yeah
so um yeah you seem to have gone quiet
again so I guess we're
yeah how long we've been talking
probably been for two hours huh one hour
and 41 minutes yeah that's about two
hours unless you guys want to talk about
anything else man we'll just split
you guys are [__] sleeping
[Laughter]
it's true
you hungry
yeah
what you thought was good what you got
yeah I got stuff down there I can make
like what
got ramen
yeah I always like Ramen
I was like Ramen yeah I got ramen
that'll be good
but yeah
all right go ahead
go ahead and shut it down it's the
beginning of a three-day weekend yeah
everybody's kind of like yeah you know
all right so uh so we'll be back on
Sunday just like usual at 6 PM EST
probably talk about I don't know which
one do you want to watch first black
Stock and Two smoke I don't know either
I don't know either one of them I mean
they're both good yeah
barrels or a snatch it'll be one of
those two uh so yes we'll uh talk about
that on Sunday so hopefully you guys can
hang out with us on Sunday so have a
good weekend uh you know up until then
and we'll see you guys again on Sunday
night good night